parlons maintenant de l'emploi des
personnes handicapées coup de projecteur
sur l'entreprise promut dijon depuis 26
ans elle forme accompagne et embauchent
des personnes handicapées au début de
l'année elle s'est même diversifié
parlons-en avec sylvain du pic
prenez votre temps y'a pas de soucis
bonjour et bienvenue donc promut dijon
est une entreprise de ce qu'elle propose
essentiellement des emplois aux
personnes handicapées est-ce que c'est
sa mission
oui tout à fait le promu est une
entreprise agréée par par l'état qui
elle a concouru elle a conclu un contrat
d'objectif à la fois social et
économique et elles emploient
majoritairement des personnes en
situation de handicap donc sur un
effectif de 250 salariés
il y à 210 personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap
lorsque l'on parle de handicap de quel
type de handicap
le handicap est très variable on préfère
plutôt oublié le mot handicapé par les
deux compétences et les adapter aux
postes à pourvoir
quels sont justement les différents
postes à pourvoir les différentes
activités de l'entreprise alors nous
avons trois activités
l'activité principale et hygiène et
propreté qui commence par un nettoyage
de bureaux nettoyage de camions
frigorifiques nettoyage industriel
bionettoyage toute une gamme très
étendue jusqu'aux la sortie de
conteneurs nettoyage des vitres etc
ensuite nous avons l'actif des travaux
paysagers qui consiste à créer et
entretenir des espaces verts et puis une
activité multiservices avec être très
variées c'est de la prestation sur
mesure avec notamment les travaux de
rénovation et travaux de peinture
prestations d'accueil notamment sur la
belgique
on va revenir sur ces différentes
activités rom ou quand même des salariés
quel est le profil des de ses salariés
inscrits sont essentiellement jeune ou
pas alors le public prioritaire ce sont
les moins de 26 ans et les plus de 50
ans et nous accueillons aujourd'hui
majoritairement quand même des personnes
qui ont plus de 50 ans donc qu'ils sont
dans une deuxième carrière
professionnelle qui ont été déclarés
inaptes dans leur première dans une
entreprise classique et qui terminent
leur carrière professionnelle au sein
d'une entreprise adaptée
ça veut dire
dans votre entreprise on est de passage
on peut vraiment faire sa carrière
la moyenne d'ancienneté moyenne et leur
de dix ans donc généralement on
travaille sur la durée
parce qu'il faut il nous faut du temps
il faut de la persévérance
rien n'est jamais acquis il faut en
permanence est vigilant et travailler
sur l'amélioration des compétences et
comment ces futurs salariés bien pousse
la porte de votre entreprise est ce que
ce sont des partenaires qui voulaient
renvoi oui on a un réseau de partenaires
des acteurs de l'insertion un grand
partenariat avec cap emploi et les
services de pôle emploi qui nous
adressent en permanence des candidats et
nous recrutons en permanence du 1er
janvier au 31 décembre
de manière à comment nous allons à
viviez assez restreint donc de personnes
des compétences bien spécifiques
il faut en permanence les recevoir les
accueillir leur expliquer tous les
postes que l'on peut proposer pour leur
eux aussi leur donner confiance et de au
début de l'année vous avez choisi de
vous diversifiez parce que vous lisiez
il faut pas se reposer sur vos acquis
vous avez rejoint la franchise élise
donc spécialisée dans le tri des déchets
de bureau
pourquoi cette diversification c'était
essentiel d'aller chercher de nouveaux
marchés
il était important de se différencier
pour échapper un peu à la concurrence et
est trouvée s'est orientée vers des
prestations éco responsable et il
s'engager à fond dans la transition
énergétique et ça na pas fragiliser
j'allais dire des autres activités deux
promus dijon bien au contraire ça les a
dynamisé le recyclage de déchets n'est
une continuité de des prestations de
nettoyage
on peut très bien effectuer les
nettoyages des bureaux d'une entreprise
ensuite aider le client à trier ses
déchets et ensuite après on revient les
collecter et les trier
ce sont des savoir faire qui existait
déjà au sein de de la structure en
avions déjà un parc de 40 véhicules donc
on avait des chauffeurs
on avait des locaux disponibles
donc ce n'était pas un grand pas
actuellement beaucoup réinvestir
derrière si j'ai néanmoins on a depuis
le début de l'année nous avons investi
toutes activités confondues plus de
300000 euros et vous réussissez à vous y
retrouver
on espère beaucoup on a un plan de
marche c'est à dire que on doit
retrouver l'équilibré à partir de la
deuxième année donc fin 2007 début 2018
pour concrétiser nos hypothèses oui
parce que sur ces trois ans donc vous
conter à créer une dizaine d'emplois est
ce que vous en avez déjà créé on a déjà
créé six emplois depuis le début de
l'année dans avec des métiers assez
nouveau pour nous qui sont des mosquées
des métiers de commerce la prospection
donc de deux collecteurs et des
chauffeurs qui vont aller chercher les
îles les gisements chez nos clients et
puis de deux agents de tri donc avec de
nouvelles compétences collègues de
thales en pet ans et qui peut aussi
s'adapter au vieillissement de notre
population parce que ce sont les postes
de tri sont des postes moins physique et
plus méticuleux un mot quand même je
sais qu'il ne reste pas beaucoup de
temps mais il ya de plus en plus de
postes adaptés pour les personnes
handicapées pourtant le chômage dans
cette catégorie de la population est
élevé est-ce que vous qui êtes là depuis
une vingtaine d'années vous voyez
vraiment les choses avancer ou pas oui
les choses avancent mais il faut
continuer on a un formidable défi à
relever qui est la transition
énergétique et tous les métiers qui vont
à nouveau qui vont être créés sont des
véritables opportunités pour nos
personnes en situation de handicap merci
beaucoup d'être venu nous parler donc de
votre société et plus de renseignement
bien sûr sur notre site internet et puis
autre exemple de diversification vous
devez connaître d'ailleurs après à la
création d'un restaurant en 2015 les adh
de fontaine les dijon en côte d'or vient
d'ouvrir dans sur le quartier vanille à
dijon une nouvelle activité saine de la
blanchisserie reportage michel giraud et
jean louis saint tin
c'est en février 2015 que les actes de
fontaine-lès-dijon ouvrait ce restaurant
sur le quartier de valmy pour les
responsables de l'aide par le travail
les prestations de services en plus
d'avenir que les activités historiques
du secteur tels que conditionnement ou
sous traitance aujourd'hui l'intervalle
en croit toujours une vingtaine de
personnes et dans une annexe du bâtiment
c'est une blanchisserie repasserie qui
vient de s'installer ici quelques
employés en situation de déficience
intellectuelle s'applique à rendre un
linge impeccable à la clientèle
collectivités ou particuliers ont fait
même du travail des particuliers alidade
aussi des particuliers comme vous comme
vernis du linge le client et il veut
avoir il veut voir son travail par
détails propres pour pauline rapport
bien payé comme il faut pas trop depuis
non pli passe quatre mots c'est pas bon
pas beaucoup certaine addiction
ils ont un travail qui sont reconnus ils
ont un salaire ils font quelque chose
d'utile et sur sera accompagné par des
moniteurs ou des éducateurs qui sont
l'ajustement au quotidien pour leur
montrer pour leurs guides et pour les
faire progresser aussi vers miller
d'hiver c'est toujours l'objectif
mais mais mais certains sont épanouis et
souhaite rester en esat pour ces raisons
là de fait les sorties vers le milieu de
travail ordinaire restent rares
michael par exemple travaillent à des
autres depuis dix ans et s'y sent bien
cette atmosphère de bienveillance me
laisse l'esprit libre pour se cultiver
sur l'histoire de l'évolution urbaine de
dijon il est incollable aussi fort qu au
pillage de linge